all right have soaring prices gotten
your attention yet
the national average for a gallon of gas
has gone up 10 days in a row and we've
set a new record for the 10th straight
day most analysts expect prices to keep
climbing at least one analyst with j.p
morgan says a national average of six
dollars a gallon is possible
now meanwhile to make a bad situation
worse we actually may be facing a
shortage of truckers soon the owner
operators are facing what's called an
existential crisis due to the
skyrocketing cost of diesel fuel
and food prices
forget about it the bloomberg headline
today caught my uh eye
chicken wings for thirty four dollars
pent up inflation driving food costs
even higher
consumer prices of food were up nine
point four percent in april compared to
prices from last april
it's the biggest gain since 1981
holy smokes
it's now time to ask this question
at both a global and a national level
is the economic chaos unfolding right
before our eyes the result of
incompetence
or careful planning
now ted cruz believes this is all
purposeful
joe biden believes if gas is five
dollars a gallon or six dollars a gallon
or ten dollars a gallon
that if he imposes enough pain
that eventually everyone will have this
this this epiphany
and get rid of that truck or get rid of
that minivan and everyone will go buy an
electric car
the angle does not disagree
of course biden is plenty ignorant we
know that and his cabinet is woefully
unqualified we know that
but the headwinds that americans are now
facing in almost every aspect of our
lives
cannot be an accident
none of this was predestined
now the biden team chose to cancel oil
leases
to stop keystone
ramp up all those regulations they green
lit a proxy war against russia
that through tens of billions of
military aid to ukraine oh yeah we can
afford that they paid people not to work
even after vaccines were available
of course they bailed out the blue
states that refused to open with biden's
so-called recovery act as well they
allowed millions of migrants we're
paying for that through the southern
border they're ceding u.s authority to
international bureaucracies and to this
day
they refuse to stop scaring americans
about covet
oh
for good measure they're even
threatening free speech
hate speech of course is anything they
disagree with
now i could go on and on but these
policies are all designed to make you
poorer and make you more dependent on
the government
force you to stop driving so much stop
attending school board meetings domestic
terrorist you stop posting all your
views online no no no dangerous it's all
geared toward limiting your freedom and
limiting your expectations
so in the globalist mindset america has
no right to be any wealthier any freer
or any happier than countries in let's
say
africa or middle east europe
then candidate barack obama was
pretty explicit i was on the radio back
then when this happened about this whole
american reset idea back in 2008
we can't
drive our suvs
and
you know eat as much as we want and keep
our homes on
you know 72 degrees at all times and
then just expect
that every other country's gonna say
okay
now i know what you're thinking
bleep other countries that was my
reaction when i first heard that all
those years ago 14 years ago
and they're always quick to downplay the
idea of american greatness
i believe in american exceptionalism
just as i suspect that
the brits believe in british
exceptionalism and the greeks believe in
greek exceptionalism
in other words we're no more exceptional
than any other country out there then a
few years later his energy secretary
slipped on the issue of gas prices
telling the wall street journal somehow
we have to figure out how to boost the
price of gasoline to the levels in
europe tried to recant that later on but
sorry we have the we have the actual
quote
now they've always liked europe better
than the united states anyway we
embarrass them
especially when they're at their fancy
global meetings and conferences
americans really embarrass them and
speaking of the rich and powerful from
big government big tech big pharma big
banks and big entertainment are
descending on the picturesque mountain
town
of davos switzerland this weekend for
the world economic forum you weren't
invited
their motto there by the way is always
committed to improving the state of the
world
arriving on private jets with bogus
carbon offsets they plot and plan their
big ideas for tackling big problems
we have really to continue and even
amplify our measures uh
in in relation to climate change to
address the deep rooted inequalities in
the labor market we need a new social
contract and it needs to be inclusive we
establish trust in our ability to shape
our common future
in collective and constructive ways
that last man was klaus schwab you know
he is the man in charge at davos and
he's famous for pushing the global reset
of capitalism which the biden folks are
fully on board with
but they of course call it something
different
plus you're going to be living in a new
normal whether that means wearing a mask
working in shifts what we have to do is
to design a new normal i hope
the new normal also includes
a real strong corporate memory
of what pandemics can do
so we don't just go on
when we get this under control
that was fouchy at davos earlier this
year by the way
now this year's davos theme is history
at a turning point with the goal of
rebuilding societal trust through
multilateral agreements supposedly
crucial to a global recovery
so all next week folks like john kerry
and al gore oh boy talk about gas bags
we'll sit on panels opining on all the
ways that the nation state that old
thing you know the country thing which
they think has failed that that should
give way to globalism pure and simple
the attendees are overwhelmingly well
healed now many are millionaires
billionaires nothing wrong with that but
they maybe feel like less icky about how
they made their money by going to davos
so their connection to davos allows them
to kind of play humanitarian for a
weekend
comedian and youtuber russell brand had
an interesting take on the crowd
if you wanna improve the state of the
world
don't invite the people that are most
responsible for ruining the thing
in the first place these are the people
that are causing the bloody
problem the fact is
brand is right and schwab in a way is
right about one thing
history is at a turning point
globalization is showing its true
outcomes isn't it china is getting
richer we are getting poorer and
meanwhile the supply chain that's broken
the expert class is failing speaking of
fouchy from lockdowns to vaccine
mandates the people who responsible for
all that they should frankly put in jail
at this point
we now know they were people that we
were supposed to trust but
now we see they were just political
hacks all along
top government officials they're not on
team usa people like treasury secretary
janet yellen who used to be fed chair
she denied the obvious that inflation
was coming and now she wants to use her
failure as an excuse to lift tariffs on
china think about that for a moment
so yes we are at a turning point
we'll either remain a free and
independent america or we're going to
spend the next few decades being pushed
around locked down and ordered around by
people you wouldn't trust to mow your
lawn
they offer you nothing but misery and
shared scarcity
let's remember jimmy carter because he
took it kind of that same platform to
the country in 1980 and he lost
spectacularly
but now all those years later in 2022
the democrats and their globalist pals
abroad are trying to convince us again
that more government control and less
freedom is actually a good thing for us
and the planet
good luck with that kids
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else